One Man created all of the early Star
Wars music composer John Williams but
many others have followed in his
footsteps in recent years including
Kevin kiner who created the score for
Ahsoka this is not kainer's first foray
into the music of the Star Wars Universe
by any means kiner says he was inspired
by William's work early on in his career
and he went on to compose the music for
the animated series The Clone Wars
Rebels the bad batch and tales of the
Jedi over the years he's put his own
spin on the Star Wars Sound by
introducing a lot of percussion
initially under George Lucas's
instructions and focusing on electronic
sound working on Ahsoka is a full circle
moment for kainer the theme song for
ahsoka's character was the first project
he worked on for Dave filoni and George
Lucas he explained to cine concerts I
remember writing for that theme and I
used a Japanese flute called a
shakuhachi just trying to feel her
femininity but her strength there's this
light and there's a Darkness to her and
there's both of that in her theme you
know there were so many elements I was
trying to put in ahsoka's theme and I'm
really proud of ahsoka's theme